yeah you
all right lawyer
lawyer
lawyer
we have a warrant for your arrest you
can get a lawyer you're holding yourself
lawyer william stern you are under
arrest for insider trading and
securities
you have the right to remain silent you
might want to exercise that come on
let's go smart guy
that was kelly o'coin who plays dollar
bill stern a cut-throat wall street
trader on one of my favorite shows the
showtime drama billions that series
plays out everything you hate about new
york's world of finance brazen
corruption unchecked power toxic
masculinity and voracious greed and no
matter what this untouched class of
financiers does they always seem to come
out on top rarely is there wrongdoing
met with consequences the kind of
consequences that you and i might face
it's just one cushy deal after another
billions was inspired by the actions of
real-life prosecutors of the rich and
powerful like preet bharara and eliot
spitzer and it's often hard to separate
out the fact from the fiction remember
not a single wall street bank boss was
prosecuted for their role in the 2008
financial crash not a one and as for the
pandemic over the summer the wall street
journal reported that the big banks are
set for big profits in fact u.s
billionaires have seen their wealth
surge by 1.8 trillion dollars during the
pandemic meanwhile millions of americans
have had their pandemic unemployment
benefits cut off and are ready for
eviction and are getting ready for
eviction notices at their doorsteps so
if you think billionaires are our only
villains on tv shows well you're not
paying attention
i'm joined now by the man who plays on
the screen the cheapest millionaire in
america kelly o'coin or dollar bill from
billions kelly thanks so much for coming
on the show tonight how did you come to
play this now almost iconic character
dollar bill stern and how much is he you
because i believe you initially turned
the roll down
uh first of all thank you i appreciate
iconic i'll take that i'm gonna make
sure my agent gets that
uses that word uh to describe it in the
future um
i came about it like everybody else i
auditioned for the role um i had i
initially turned it down because i
auditioned for a larger role that was
definitely going to be a recurring role
in the show and they liked what i did
but they didn't think it matched what
they were looking for for this other
character so they asked me to read for
dollar bill and it didn't even guarantee
it was recurring so i thought it was a
one-off and i said no
and then of course of the weekend i
thought more and i was thinking about
the people involved and the fact that
he's got a funny nickname and the fact
that they already have a description
that he's the cheapest millionaire in
america and it just struck me that maybe
there would be some growth potential for
the role
uh and the smartest decision i've ever
made in my career was that following
monday email my agents and say can i
still get in and and i was able to
and no oh and i am so let's talk my wife
has told me if you ever bring an ounce
of this guy into the house you're out my
friend so i will tell you that i i love
my wife more i love misbehaving dollar
bill
you're one wife in real life as opposed
to your two fictional wives on the show
let's talk about let's talk about
billions uh the new season is currently
on show time on sunday nights i want to
play a clip from season 3 though have a
watch
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
you're laughing i'm laughing out loud
watching i watch that so many times is
billions kelly supposed to be a show in
which viewers are turned off by the
unchecked capitalism and toxic behavior
that they see on screen the one percent
is behaving badly or are they supposed
to be turned on is it a guilty pleasure
to want to root for acts and wags and
dollar bill
i think
i'm not in the heads of the creators of
the show um
i don't know what they set out to do and
what they may have shifted into
attempting to do what i will say
from my perspective is i appreciate that
i have my take on
i think the show does ask a question
underneath everything i think it asks
the question or at least suggests the
question
whether or not it's possible to be a
deca billionaire
um
a big billy as they say
and to still be a good person
and that is a question it
allows the audience to uh answer it
doesn't i appreciate that it doesn't
beat you over the head with moralizing i
think there are built-in criticisms i
think it is true to um to what we know
in the world that there are
uh few and far between perhaps
satisfying
uh consequences that some misbehaving uh
agents
uh meet
so
yeah
is it fair to say just for our viewers
at home that kelio coined views on
bankers and wall street traders and
hedge funds is very different to dollar
bills views you're someone who thinks we
should take a harsher more bernie-esque
line with wall street is that fair
i i what i will say is yes absolutely
i have a different point of view from
dollar bill um
i
i don't think that every regulations is
every regulation
um
means that you're a socialist every time
you try to provide protections it means
you're a socialist
um it it
it doesn't me i don't believe that that
infrastructure is simply bridges and
roads i believe that infrastructure in a
new world perhaps means a little more i
do think that perhaps some sort of green
new deal
could transform our economy and if you
are
a capitalist and believe in the
capitalist system then you must believe
that it can evolve and grow and actually
work for people
um but it has to have protections for
people as well
music to my ears i think it's fair to
say the viewers would agree um so kelly
just listening to you speak there
you follow politics you sound quite
political yourself you sound like you're
on the left not the right your father
lezzo coin was a member of congress from
oregon i believe he campaigned against
reagan's support for the contras
campaigned uh for environmental
protections your mother susan worked for
the national abortion rights action
league i wonder how much impact is your
upbringing having parents like that
yes i have some parents like that with
their impressive resumes how much did
that impact you your upbringing the
causes you advocate for today how
political was your household growing up
oh it's very political um and and
more importantly specific i would say it
was an activist uh
fighting the good fight was not a cliche
it wasn't something you you cringed at
it wasn't a cute little aphorism
fighting the good fight was something
people actually said in my household uh
and believed it um
and
it
the politic my dad would come home from
a session uh talking about the mx
missile and we would over dinner because
he always came home for dinner which was
i don't know how he did that with a
congressman's schedule sometimes he went
back to work afterwards
um but he would talk to us about what
the debate was and he would lay things
out in a way that was so clear i always
admired him for that he was
he was a democrat as howard dean would
say from he was from the democratic wing
of the democratic party
he
um
he was
progressive he also was um was somebody
who understood that
um
i i would guess to say i would venture
to say you could have him on as well but
that he was a he was not an
anti-capitalist necessarily but he he
wanted a capitalism that actually had
checks
capitalism that actually was not
unfettered and something that actually
worked for people
uh and the nuclear freeze was one of his
early issues and i could go on i i i'm a
fanboy of my dad i have to say
and what are the issues you're
advocating for nancy what are the issues
that you feel strongly about
voting rights is probably right at the
top right now um
i have had so many arguments with people
who um
uh
who didn't vote in the last couple
elections and when i because i just
i couldn't get them to see beyond
the to my mind misguided notion that the
candidates were the same
and i would always bring up the um
the supreme court and a number of people
would say look i'm not a one-issue voter
and my stance was always that's not one
issue that's all the issues and i see we
are we are now
here or we're on the verge of seeing the
consequences of that kind of to my mind
lazy thinking
um
anyway voting rights um vote writers
r-i-d-e-r-s is a great organization
non-partisan organization that simply
helps people navigate voter id laws
um fair fight um
and um and also i'm on the board of
autism rights and
acceptance organization called culture
city and we advocate for the rights of
people on spectrum with sensory needs by
helping them provide access to spaces
that are usually off
off limits to them we've also been
working with police stations
um trying to train um some of these
officers all the officers actually
that's our goal in the country
to learn
behaviors and what that might mean other
than just raw aggression
i mean activism is so important as you
mentioned just a moment ago you grew up
not in a political household but an
activist household you then became an
actor i'm not sure what your parents
made of that another role you're known
for as an actor is your role as pastor
tim in the spy drama the americans which
was on fx although a lot of people
didn't realize that dollar bill and
pastor tim are the same person let's
watch a clip of you being confronted in
the americans by the lead character the
russian sleeper agent philip
jennings i'll write you a check right
now if you want but
that's not why you're here
no it's not
[Music]
are you really gonna beat me up
mr jennings
for 600
for your daughter i would do anything
for my daughter
i would do anything for my daughter
best thing you can do for her is find a
way to deal with your anger
kelly i love that show too it was a show
all about russian espionage and sleeper
agents in america and its final two
seasons aired around the same time as
trump's election accusations of russian
collusion the mueller inquiry did some
of that seep into the show did you feel
the real world politics the russia angle
on set
i did it was it was not
a single time that someone made the joke
about um philip and elizabeth finding
this uh
maybe a storyline could be could be uh
introduced where they find this uh
russian real estate guy and they start
developing him as an asset for the next
20
plus years um
one of the things that really resonated
with me about the character was i
remember a time because uh dollar bill
dollar pastor pastor tim
um
was an activist
um sweet caring activist
politically on the left
um
man of the cloth and
the position of the cloth the arguments
the political arguments the political
discussion around uh religion and people
of religion has been co-opted by the
right and um i i appreciate the fact
that this is representing a time when
that wasn't the case and my dad a
liberal democrat worked
really successfully with a number of uh
of progressive churches back in the day
and i love the fact that i told joel
fields and joey interesting the creators
of the show that the that was one of the
things that really drew me to the role
and um and the truth in that i thought
to extend it was such a great hit
no it's such a great role we're out of
time sadly but it's such a great role i
urge everyone to watch the americans and
of course you can catch new episodes of
billions every sunday night on showtime
kelly o'coin it's been an absolute
pleasure thank you for being on the show
tonight